hey guys i'm jasmine and i love
boba you might have seen me over on
bring me trying to finish a gallon of
boba milk tea or trying unique boba
treats in taiwan because for me boba is
just one of those things that can turn a
bad day into a better one so i thought i
would share five delicious and gorgeous
boba recipes with you all so we can
enjoy them together
all right guys we're gonna start by
making the boba first we're making it
from scratch of course if you don't want
to make it from scratch you can buy
pre-made boba from any local asian
grocery store but actually making boba
from scratch is quite easy and is only
three ingredients three not six three so
let's start by adding in our water
and our muscovado sugar and we're going
to turn that on to a medium high heat
we're going to stir this until it
dissolves and comes to a boil it's
starting to boil so i am going to add in
a little bit of tapioca flour you want
to mix this in well because we don't
want these clumps if you find that
you're clumping too much you can add a
little bit of water to make that
dissolve just a little bit easier once
it looks something like this we're going
to add in half of our tapioca mixture so
we're just going to stir this
really vigorously until it forms a super
sticky dough now that you got a super
sticky dough like this we're going to
turn the heat off we're going to add in
the rest of our tapioca flour and once
that forms into a ball we're going to
move over to a new workstation and roll
out the dough i just let our boba dough
cool for a little bit and i'm
transferring it onto this clean counter
and i'm just going to incorporate all
the tapioca flour into the dough if your
dough feels a little dry you can add a
little bit more water if you feel like
your dough is too wet you can add a
little bit more tapioca flour i'm just
gonna knead it until it's all
incorporated once your dough is formed
it should look something like this roll
it into a thick little oval like this
like a potato i split it in half and
then we can easily roll both out if it
gets too long you can separate them
when you think it's the right size make
it just a little bit smaller because it
does expand when you cook it and the
boba dough does get harder to roll once
it cools down so if you want you can put
like a warm wet towel over part of the
dough while you're rolling out the other
part alrighty so i have four
thinly rolled boba dough logs and i am
just going to put them together
and i'm going to be cutting them into
small little boba pieces i think a
quarter inch it's also okay that they're
not all uniform so now that we've gotten
them into our little baby pieces we roll
them up into little balls let me show
you a couple hacks on how i make this a
little quicker of a process so of course
you can do it one by one like this and
you have your little boba or sometimes
i'm able to put five on my palm i'll put
my palm over the other and after some
good old rolling you'll have your
delicious boobas uh it didn't work
today's not a good day all right so
after some time rolling you'll be able
to see that they come out like this
perfect and then we throw them into a
bowl with some tapioca flour and make
sure they're well coated so they don't
stick to each other the other hack is
spreading them onto the cutting board or
your counter wherever workspace that you
choose and just go to town
if you occasionally feel lazy in the
kitchen like me then this hack is great
but make sure your dough isn't too cold
or this hack won't work tada look at
that little boba babies i call it boba
but you know
in different parts of the world they are
called something different boba bubble
tea pearls in taiwan they say
which is pearl
now that the water has come to a rolling
boil we're going to add in all of our
boba and we're going to stir it so it
doesn't stick together it's going to
turn a little cloudy just because of
that excess tapioca flour that was
coating it you can mainly leave it
unbothered for the next 20 minutes or so
while the boba's cooking let's make our
brown sugar syrup it's very simple we're
just gonna add in some mascarpono sugar
and some water i'm gonna mix it and let
it reduce just a little bit so it's nice
and viscous now we are going to pour it
into this heat resistant glass over here
yes
gorgeous so now that the bulb is done
we're gonna drain it and rinse it with
cold water to keep it from cooking even
more and then we're gonna give our boba
a brown sugar bath you hear that
so we're gonna leave our bobas in this
brown sugar syrup bath for about 30
minutes to an hour just so it can really
soak up that delicious deep flavor of
the musca bottle sugar yum
i put this one first because i think
everyone trying boba for the first time
should definitely try the classic boba
milk tea experience the first step for
making a boba milk tea is to make our
tea my favorite part is when the tea bag
hits the water and then that heat that
is slowly bubbling up it causes that tea
leaf to just release its gorgeous dark
brown hue and you can see those swirls
in the water and then you take your
spoon that's my favorite part you press
on the tea bag and it just like
explodes with color
so while the tea is cooling down we're
gonna make our milk mixture i personally
love using condensed milk because i
think it gives it a much richer flavor
it makes your boba milk tea
multi-dimensional and i want every
experience with my boba to be
multi-dimensional once you have those
two together you can whisk
until it's combined so this condensed
milk mixture does make your drink even
sweeter especially with the muscovado
sugar bath that the boba is currently in
so if you prefer your drinks to be less
sweet you can just sub it with more
black tea on average when i go to boba
shops i get a 25 or 50 sweet time to
assemble our first drink so we're gonna
start by adding in our boba and then add
in some ice and then we're gonna add in
our black tea and top it with our
sweetened milk i like to add it slowly
over a spoon to slow down that pour and
really get those swirls you can see that
i'm actually failing here but it's okay
because it's still pretty and delicious
and voila that's our first drink the
classic black milk tea with boba
wow that is so good
all right guys the next drink we're
making is a mango slush with boba it's
absolutely delicious it was one of my
childhood favorites because it's just so
sweet and
summery and refreshing it's super easy
take your blender and we're going to add
in some frozen mango chunks some water
and some condensed milk and just blend
away
once we've blended everything together
we can grab a glass and i'm adding in
some boba that we made earlier and of
course topping it with our mango
smoothie look at how beautiful it is i
love it time to drink the mango smoothie
with boba this will be a throwback
mmm mango smoothie guys i mean come on
it's so refreshing
[Music]
the next drink we are going to make is a
strawberry matcha latte let's start by
making our strawberry puree we're going
to add in half a cup of diced
strawberries and two tablespoons of
sugar we're gonna muddle it with a fork
until it's nice and juicy you can muddle
it to your liking so if you like chunks
in your drink feel free to leave some
chunks now that we have it muddled we're
gonna let it sit for 10 minutes so while
that's sitting we're going to go and
make our tea we're going to add a
teaspoon of matcha powder to a third cup
of hot water and whisk it until bubbles
form on the surface if you don't have a
whisk or a matcha whisk don't worry you
can totally just use a fork
we're gonna add in our boba per the
usual and then we're gonna top it with
our muddled strawberries now put in the
ice after the strawberries this will
help with the layering we're gonna
slowly add in the half and half the last
step for this drink is to add our matcha
again slowly pour it over this drink
this drink is like very anxiety heavy
huh slowly
oh slowly slowly look guys it's so
pretty strawberry matcha latte the
colors are just absolutely gorgeous
if you're trying to impress your friends
this is a drink to make but i have to
mix it i'm sad i have to but you know
it's just the way things are it actually
is still very pretty those chunks of
strawberry are giving it a nice hint of
red cheers
[Music]
it's the perfect blend of matcha and
strawberry it's light creamy and fruity
i got a mouthful of strawberry puree and
i'm in heaven
this is the taro milky with boba it has
a nuttiness to it that the other drinks
don't have so i've already steeped my
green tea and let it come to room
temperature and now i'm going to whisk
my taro powder into the green tea if you
haven't had taro before taro is a root i
would compare it to a sweet potato but
slightly more bland and slightly more
sweet it's very delicious you can also
sub the green tea with water if you're
not looking for a caffeine kick but
trust me the taste with the green tea
just elevates it to a whole other level
let's get to assembling add in our boba
add some ice and then pour the taro tea
into the glass and then slowly add in
our two tablespoons of half and half
again if you want that gorgeous swirl
you can pour it slowly over the back of
a spoon mix it up and it's time to drink
cheers
[Music]
when you are chewing it and the flavor
of the taro milk tea is fusing with the
boba flavor next level guys next level
this is like the big home run because i
think it's the prettiest this is the pt
latte with boba if you don't know what
pt is it's a type of tea derived from
the butterfly pea flower and it has this
beautiful blue color and if you squeeze
a lemon into it it turns
purple look at that a purple tee we're
gonna steep a teaspoon of loose pt
leaves in a cup of hot water for about
five minutes and then we're gonna strain
it and let it come to room temperature
that's essentially it it's time to
assemble and we're gonna start by adding
in our boba ice and then pour in our pt
oh it's so pretty look at that blue i
almost don't want to ruin it it's just
so gorgeous but we are we're going to
add in a couple tablespoons of half and
half
and it will look like you're drinking
the ocean and there you have it the pt
latte with boba it's so gorgeous let's
give it a try
i would say it tastes like a very very
light version of thai tea so if you
enjoy lighter teas this may be for you
there you have it five must try boba
recipes that are delicious unique and
beautiful
if you end up making any of these boba
recipes or all of the boba recipes make
sure to tag me on instagram so i can see
it bye
oh yes
[Music]
do
[Music]